le mec le mieux coiffés de la planète
regardez il va apparaître la regarde et
sont donald trump
[Applaudissements]
franchement il a comme un renard qui
bouge
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé quelles
infos se cache derrière cette image pour
la première fois il ya twitter qui a
signalé un tweet de donald trump en
disant que c'était potentiellement
défectueuses mais c'est incroyable alors
eh oui c'est une première dans
l'histoire de twitter la plateforme a
signalé qu'un tweet du président
américain était trompeur
regardez on vous récapitule la faire
c'est complètement ouf mais twitter en
ce moment ils ont ils ont raison ils
sont chauds et surtout même sur vous
mais name ah oui bah ouais on dirait
m'ont dit vous allez voir ça va chier
pour vous regardez c'est la première
fois que ça arrive le réseau social
twitter a décidé de s'en prendre
publiquement à donald trump qui pourtant
depuis le début de son mandat se sert de
la plateforme comme journal officiel
mais cette fois ci face à deux fêtes
news twitter a décidé de réagir en
signalant les messages de donald trump
deux messages au sujet du vote par
correspondance mis en place aux états
unis un vote qu'il juge frauduleuse face
à ces messages twitter a tenu à ajouter
une mention ses tweets contiennent des
informations potentiellement trompeuses
immédiatement donald trump s'est énervé
contre cette mesure de la part de
twitter twitter étouffe la liberté
d'expression une bataille de la fecq
news plus que jamais d'actualité dans
une année présidentielle cruciale aux
états unis
alors est-ce que c'est pas petit buzz de
twitter mine de rien ils sont dix alors
certes ça va être un buzz énorme bon moi
je pense que oui
allez-y vous je crois pas parce que je
crois qu'en ce moment de feutre en train
de se bouger un peu les fesses parce que
quand on signale une personne on
ressemble beaucoup plus rapidement la
réponse que d'habitude
et hier avec ce qui s'est passé en
plateau j'ai eu un message de twitter
qui m'a demandé si j'étais intéressé
pour tester le nouveau truc ou quand on
tweet si on décide que ce soit hollande
qui voit que ce soit que les gens que je
follow qui puisse répondre ou que
personne ne réponde bouger sur le
twitter vous j'ai testé j'ai fait un
tweet effet [ __ ] plus personne ne
pouvait commenter le tweet a beaucoup
reproché à twitter de noël de rien faire
du tout et en mars dernier ils ont déjà
supprimé 2 tweets du président brésilien
qui remettait en cause oui et en fait
twitter maintenant est en train de
vraiment être une puissance et les
présidents et autres et dirigeants se
rendre compte et notamment donald trump
qui a réagi en disant je vais aller
mettre mon nez sur les plateformes et je
vais faire en gros un petit peu le
ménage
donc évidemment aux états unis ça ça ça
bruisse dans tous les sens en disant à
temps à maurice il veut aller censurer
les réseaux sociaux etc et donc va y
avoir une vraie bataille ça va aussi se
jouer notamment la bataille des
élections va aussi se jouer sur les
réseaux sociaux
il a été élu sur les réseaux sociaux
mais lui grâce à twitter me dont il a
été lui grâce à deux buts et à twitter
donc il peut pas mine de rien cracher
dans la soupe comme on dit voilà chez
liebig